this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's the last day of the
month and Halloween you bad
[__] stay away from that black
cat the joint is brought to you by
liquid IV Uncle Joy's morning routine
always starts with liquid IV it helps me
get my day started like a soldier with
one stick of liquid IV you're getting
two times faster hydration than with
water alone
I love the flavors
concord grape the Cherry the tropical
punch tremendous you bring them in your
little container while you work out
during workout what makes liquid IV so
effective is the cellular transport
technology designed to enhance
absorption of water into the bloodstream
liquid IV is non-GMO free from gluten
dairy and soy liquid IV contains five
essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C and three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks so stop [__] around let's get
on boat with the liquid IV I love it
grab your liquid IV and bulk nationwide
at Costco or you get 10 off when you go
to liquid iv.com Joey again save that 15
go to liquid iv.com Joey that's 15 off
anything you order when you shop for
better hydration at liquid iv.com
um slash Joey and now without further
Ado let's get this little party started
on a Monday morning
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey coming out here on a
beautiful Monday morning October the
31st tricky tricky [__] this is
it
it's Halloween day I'm excited this
whole weekend felt like [__] a
Halloween
extravaganza uh it started Friday
Saturday we had some [__] oh she had the
kickbox and stuff at school she had to
dress up whatever I don't even know what
we did Saturday night I didn't do much
obviously the World Series I think I
watched Friday night Philadelphia is on
the [__] map bringing that party back
to Philly tonight they're playing in
Philadelphia Halloween night I gotta
tell you something in my world that's
not [__] good man that's not [__]
good I love Philadelphia I love
everything about Philadelphia I was
telling somebody the first time
that I really realized what the [__] was
going on in Philly I got a ton of [__]
to say today but since you guys got me
started on Philly
it had to be like 81 82 8 like I had
been to Philly a bunch
like I had been to Philly a [__]
Bunch guys when I was a kid I had been
there to see the stones and I just come
down here to some [__] pool and I
came to see Black Sabbath and I came to
see another band down here I always
liked Philadelphia
and one night we were watching we were
[__] about to go out and I saw in the
paper
that the Lakers were playing the
Phillies
uh the Phillies the Lakers are playing
the players are playing the Sixers and
a bunch of us like three three or four
of us I called one guy and I go listen
man
I think this is the Year Julie is
serving pulls it off with Moses Malone
the Lakers are giving Philly a point who
the [__] are the Lakers to give Philly a
[__] point at home that's a
completely different [__] situation
Philly at home in those days Philly at
home any [__] day is completely
different as a stadium experience or an
arena experience at any other Stadium
they're going to torture you and that
you're gonna get hit with french fries
it's a complete different situation so
we got in the car we had to Philly sure
enough we put a bed in and to my uh
Philly won the game it was that if you
ever see that [__] game when Julia
serving got the ball and he cupped it
against Michael Cooper and they slammed
it that's the game we were at for like
20 bucks like in the second area there
jumping up and down it was phenomenal
but in those days if you scored 125
points something anybody who's from
Philly and is my age or remember this if
the sixes scored 125 points you got a
free [__] cheeseburger guys just some
shitty [__] cheeseburger no big deal
but when you're 19 years old that
cheeseburger goes a long way you just
put away five bucks that you could use
for a bit later on
so I don't know I don't know if we had
the coupons that night I don't know if
we didn't get them but we went to a
hamburger place Philly if anybody
remembers this place please let me know
and we get there and [__] half the
game is at the stand
you know I mean I don't know how many
that had to be [__] 3 000 people
there well that's what it seemed like
the line was off the [__] ass but
after about an hour we're out there
giggling and having a good time and by
the time we get to close to the door
you're in Philly a fight breaks out
right
just like three dudes fought like two
other dudes this went on for about 15
minutes
the people I had grown up with
they were ready to [__] jump in there
and [__] but
nobody on that line moved like it seemed
like usually when there's a fight people
turn around people watch people clap
people say call the police
guys nobody said a word which made me
believe that this is an everyday
occurrence down here that people are
waiting online for [__] hamburgers
and also they just banging out with each
other but it gets better
some way the fight ended
but somebody went to his car and got
like a [__] hammer
not a stick not a knife not a gun he
came back with like a [__] hammer and
he hit the other kid in the [__] head
with it guys you can't write this [__]
I'm 19. I'm 20. maybe 21 maybe maybe no
I'm [__] 20. you can't write this
[__] he hit him with a [__] Hammer
right in the [__] head caved in his
[__] head eyeball was out the guys on
the floor
do you know how long it took the people
in Philly to go over and help that
[__] there was no brotherly love
in that [__] that day because
nobody gave a [__] about that dude maybe
three people went over after the dust
settled when the dude with the hammer
left that's when people went over but
want to do with the hammer was there
people were just eating that
cheeseburger like it was a beautiful
[__] day at a park and I was like wow
this [__] just got hit in the
head not with a new truck not with a
fist not with a [__] ball but with a
hammer that's real guys a [__] Hammer
is real
I remember eating my burger and tell my
boys let's get the [__]
out of here let's get the [__] out we
don't even belong in this [__]
and now like you hear about all this
violence and [__] like this across the
country like oh my God and that story
goes right into what I saw two years
later in San Francisco when they stabbed
the [__] they gutted his stomach
in front of the [__] Original Joe's
at lunch time this guy was just sitting
there with his stomach gutted the blood
wasn't even red it was that purple color
when it's just turning brown and [__]
and nobody gave a [__] it was a
different world back then but anyway
it's a beautiful day to be alive I wish
uh Philly a lot of luck tonight they
don't need my [__] luck they they've
been doing [__] great the game
Saturday night you know what are you
gonna do
Friday night they went into [__]
Houston and showed them what they could
do I'm not cheering for anybody I got
Philly for the series because it was a
long shot I love [__] on the dogs
that's my [__] world
but uh I think it's going to be
interesting I think they're playing
Monday Wednesday and Friday and I'm
gonna try with everything in my heart to
go on Friday night I got a call in there
so I don't you know I'm trying
everything
I'll take any ticket I just don't want
to stand
I don't want to stand for [__] nine
innings you know but you're in
Philadelphia so I can't even I think
people gonna go dress to the stadium
tonight in costume which means you're
gonna get hit in the head with something
because when somebody in Philadelphia
you get hit in the head just for being
down there when they're in costume they
got nowhere now it's a [__]
free-for-all you need is Ted Nugent on
the drums and somebody's getting smacked
tonight it's [__] tremendous I
[__] love Halloween I listen
last night listen Halloween wish when I
was up to about like eight
Halloween was cool you know what I'm
saying then you're like [__] Halloween
once I moved to Jersey I don't know why
when I grew up in New York nobody ever
talked about it but once I moved to
Jersey
people used to talk about Devil's Night
all right when I moved to Jersey in the
70s I didn't hear about devil's night
again until the crow came out like it
just it got invisible to me it was
something that wasn't spoken about it's
like Monday Night Football when I was
growing up Monday Night Football was
just [__] was the ship by lunchtime you
on the phone with your friends where we
going make sure Lee's this place
Shenanigans this place gives you [__]
every score was who would give you the
most food like if some place had peanuts
and chips we're not going down there for
[__] peanuts and chips by the 80s
they started giving you [__]
meatballs at Monday Night Football and
chicken wings and [__] like that so
whoever gave you the best [__] food
on Mondays that's where we're at 50 Cent
mugs of Heineken 50 Cent mugs and a
Froggers oh and a nice Frozen mug the
old days good googly moogly with a half
a gorilla biscuit on a Monday night
because you didn't have 50 bucks for
blow it's Monday you can't start the
week off strong but a little [__]
half of Quaalude that means you're both
chipped in two bucks come on a little
Quaalude your leg goes numb while you're
sitting there [__] tremendous I miss
those [__] days but anyway
I didn't discover devil's night until I
moved to [__] Jersey and it
discovered in my neighborhood all right
I grew up in uh off giving that Terrace
off 38th Street Park buck wild park
loved growing up there but craziest
[__] Part close to us I don't know
what happened up in Northern uh North
Bergen like Harvest man and Robin Fulton
craziest area by us when I was when I
first got to North Bergen was 26th
Street
it was just uh you took your [__] you
took your [__] the bus the number one
bus to 26th Street you had Roosevelt
Stadium when you got off this [__]
stadium was huge which were like Emerson
and Union Hill used to play and if you
walk down that Hill like there was a
little Bodega on the corner there that
was the home of the eggs we used to get
eggs in that [__] and then you
walked down into 26th Street and it was
like I don't want to say it's a housing
project
but it's something like all the houses
look the same all the buildings look the
same I know maybe it was a project or
whatever but it didn't matter in the 70s
it looked great and when I got to North
Bergen one of my uh like slash cousins
uh Julian lived in one of those
buildings so I I would go visit Julian I
would go visit this other Cube and his
cousin Martin Perez whose father was
Batista's driver in [__] Cuba we'll
get into that some other time so I
started with going up over there and
then they would and they would take me
around 26th Street and I got to meet the
Carver House and the arimedes and Dean
lepreet and you know I got to meet these
[__] Savages Alfred osley and [__]
just these [__] dudes that were
animals Debbie
and on on uh on devil's night we would
start off yeah you got the eggs you put
the hole in them with the needle and you
put them under your bed so when you hit
somebody with an egg it smells [__]
horrible whatever eggs you didn't hit
your friends where you hit the Hasidic
Jews with you know because that's that
was what was hip in those days I don't
mean to be striking the Jews everybody's
been beaten upon the Jews next between
Kanye and [__] Kyrie Irving a [__]
Arab is going nuts so
uh you know you had the [__] eggs
with the hole in them you had you got
sock and you put salt flour in your
socks you put up you got socks like
regular socks you doubled them up and
you put baking flour in that
[__] and when I hit you with it
powder comes out and [__]
[Music]
so I would you would have [__] egg
you get hit with an egg and then we'd
come up with a [__] sock and clock
down the head with a [__] sock and
the flower will go anywhere the power of
26th Street the power of 26th Street
that they had over any other [__]
thing was you had that place during test
up the [__] corner and duratest that
was the secret that 26th Street
possessed that Noah you know like super
power you know like uh The Avengers and
all those [__] guys have superpowers
when it came to the street devil's night
nobody had better superpowers than 26th
Street we had we had a company called
Dural test Dura test had some type of
[__] cancer powder in their light
bulbs like these light bulbs we used
they would make the long ones eight foot
ones or six foot ones the three foot
ones and they would make regular light
bulbs and throw them in a tub so we'd
either hit you with the flower or the
egg or
we'd hit you with the light bulb or the
three footer the eight footer or the 10
foot or whatever the foot can you
imagine kids running down Kennedy
Boulevard with [__] six foot white
things
like just people like what the [__] are
they doing they'd be like 10 of us
running with [__] those fluorescent
lights and when you hit somebody with
those things nothing happens to you
you're not going to lose an eye or
nothing like that but there's a residual
powder in there and that [__] lands on
you between that the flower it's the Meg
yolk you're a [__] Ghana you
understand me
Mischief Night Devil's knife a little
[__]
liquid IV I took a little concord grape
you know it's funny because everybody
said well liquid IV it's high in
potassium or high and whatever when I
went to the [__] doctor last week
and they banged me out with the blood
test that was the person they said to me
they got to start drinking more eating
more potassium vitamin D with K2 so it
gets the [__] vitamins to your
[__] arteries so it cleans out the
[__] here's to you [__] suckers a little
concord grape
nice [__]
but anyway
yeah that was Devil's Night dog and I
listen I can tell you a bunch of [__] I
never went I was only 10 12 13. I never
went outside for devil's night but
Devil's Night used to get [__] sh
like we were close to all those
cemeteries as we got old on Devil's
Night
like uh I don't know when that [__]
started we must have been like 12.
and one night somebody said they cut
through the
to the cemetery and they saw devil
worshipers in that
so especially like Devils might we'd
wait for devil's night and we wouldn't
go to the cemetery by 38th Street not
the one my mother's bury that because
then it's a small Cemetery but we would
go to the one by 46th Street up the
corner from deity Quintero and Carlos
Quintero they got Cemetery for Miles
there like I told you that 46th Street
Hills on the slant that has to be this
close so when we were kids and it would
rain the funeral the the cemeteries
would wash out and the [__] bodies
would go down the hill caskets and [__]
Carlos I'll have Carlos on the podcast
one of these days they'll tell you that
one time a casket was open it just
opened because the rain dragged it down
a hill it was a skeleton with a sweater
on you know nobody [__] saw nothing
but that's how crazy that area is
for cemeteries so I still remember a
bunch of guys going nah
devil's night we're gonna go to [__]
uh the cemetery tonight and beat some
people up this was a kid like Juan Soto
Juan Soto knocked the girl up when he
was 13. I never saw that [__]
again can you so most people have to
quit high school because they're animals
this guy had a quick grammar school like
he had a quick gram at school like I
never saw him again after seventh grade
summer but he was a crazy Cuban kid and
he had some other crazy Cuban kids Mario
Diaz these kids were out of their
[__] minds and one day they came to
me like listen dog we're going to the
cemetery tonight to beat up on devil
worshipers and throw eggs at them and
[__] chase them with Jen I'm like
come on guys and in my mind I didn't
want to go in that cemetery and I'll
tell you why because a lot of times
santeros would go in there to do uh
rituals and [__] like that if it was a
spiritual ritual I had never been
involved in anything like that as a
child or had ever heard anybody talk
about it but I'd be walking to the
cemetery sometimes and I'd see some
Santa real [__] like a dead pigeon or
something like that Santeria people kill
pigeons and chickens cats No Monkeys no
squirrels no you know dogs no no no so
if you see a dog in a cemetery that's a
devil [__] worshiper but anyway
getting back to the devil worship a
story
thank you
[Music]
so it was Halloween like 74 something
like that it was like oh this little
group was like a group of bastard kids
this wasn't like Dominic special or
Anthony balzano these are little Cuban
kids with a couple little dirty white
kids they recruited from 26th Street
field and they wanted to go up to
[__] 2016 yeah 26 2016 didn't have a
field it was just they had a basketball
court that overlooked route three so if
you ever had it into the city right boom
boom boom you see my grandma school on
the side and you see the York Hotel
you're going to see a bridge that comes
over you know like when you're hitting
Lincoln Tunnel and it says you're going
to Lincoln town and then you go into
that City that's Union City but the
first one you hit you're gonna see a
little walk there
on that corn on the top there used to be
a basketball court there that was
tremendous but the other thing was
during the summer caterpillars would
come out and you'd have to step on them
or whatever like that'd be thousands of
[__] caterpillars everywhere and you
would step on them like as a kid you
know because you're a [__] idiot and
I'll never forget I was stepping on
those [__] one day with like
earphones I couldn't hear nothing and my
friend Poncho [__] grabbed me by the
neck I almost jumped eight [__] feet
yeah I thought one of those caterpillars
came to life I was [__] petrified
but right there they all hooked up there
one night they're like we're gonna go
beat up [__] devil worshipers
so I don't know I took I think I took
like a [__] sock with flour in it and
a couple eggs and I went up there and
sure enough we're in those [__]
Cemetery like
we're in that Cemetery
like [__] 10 minutes and we hear
something this is on [__] devil's
night off of 46th Street if you go deep
deep by this point we're like on 51st
Street that's all a creepy part of that
Cemetery there and we hear something in
the weeds and sure enough hit some guy
dressed in like black with a [__]
hood or something like that and we just
shut down for like four minutes we were
kids man we're [__] kids like two
kids were scared and we were like let's
just chase them and see what happens and
we're like ah and we started chasing the
dude okay he started running and all
sudden like I I don't know I got lost
like two other guys
I'll never forget that I started seeing
my friends running back going no turn
around there's like 300 of them and then
we're like [__] this and we ran the [__]
out of there and we saw some of the guys
chasing us we never you know they wanted
to call the cops this [__] but I never
had the time we just went home we just
never went back to the cemetery that's
it end of that [__] thing no reason
to be chasing devil word I don't even
know if that was that worship is I
shouldn't say this [__] but oh my God it
was so much [__] fun Halloween and
look did I say anything about getting
candy you could take that candy and
shove it up your ass I never wanted
nobody's candy we were raised that if
you didn't give us money
like you had to give us [__] money
[__] your [__] candy okay and I'm not
talking about we were six and we already
raised you like we were already training
in money like my first trick-or-treat
ever was on Broadway
like I lived on 88th Street so my mother
goes just trick or treat on Broadway
guys if you went home with three pieces
of candy that was a lot in the 70s I
swear to God you went home you got Rosa
pennies you got tons of rolls of Penny
which is 50 [__] cents we went out to
get money
this
chocolate [__] you could take that
chocolate when we were kids if you gave
us candy we'd [__] stab you listen it
was well known
if you didn't give out good candy your
house was getting bombarded
with [__] eggs shaving cream
that [__] blue shaving cream you were
getting hit with that I mean guys
Society was so much [__] different
the cops were like I got hit with eggs
well you didn't give the kids chocolate
even the cops walking new
the cops even [__] knowing North
Bergen like that this guy didn't give
out good candy you gave out money
it was a bucket
with 70 pennies dimes and nickels maybe
[__] 10 quarters and the rest
was little there was no [__] little
bite-sized chocolate in those days they
gave you a whole [__] candy bar guys
the cheap [__] gave you
Hershey's kisses and they're not bad
then I heard she's kiss ain't bad they
would give you like 20 Hertz kisses
that's 20 cents now they give you a [__]
they got cheap over the years that's why
I usually take all the change that I
have throughout the year and I put in
the bucket and I put it out there
something a lot of patties a lot of
nickels who gives a [__] who else gives
out change
nobody so the kids are going to come
over here and they're going to go
whoever lives in the house they're
pretty cool just because I give you the
my yearly [__] pennies all that [__]
that's in your glove compartment every
time you go to Wawa or 7-Eleven and you
throw it in the cup in there see how
many pennies you got in there you got a
hundred dollars worth of [__] pennies
in there if you really think about it
when I come home at night I empty my
[__] change I give Mercy all the
[__] nickels and dimes and quarters
and they wrap them up to put away money
but the pennies nobody wants a [__]
penny except me [__] I'll [__] put
those things out for Halloween that's
how it Halloween was so [__] I
couldn't even get costumes this year for
Mercy like we got her a costume and it's
a cool costume she likes it one of those
something from uh not Black Adam
what's the other one
nah the [__] matambo whatever the
[__] black panther she got one of the
Black Panther suits the other guy told
he better put a brown with that [__]
suit you're getting old [__] suckers you
just looked at me really yeah go put on
a bra you got no mercy
but no it's uh Halloween was a [__]
yeah Halloween was a hundred dollar a
day
a lot of people don't know that [__] and
a lot of people are young they're gonna
watch this podcast and go what are you
talking about nobody gave us money on
Halloween it was a hundred dollar a day
Halloween easy easy easy
you could shake down your parents your
friends parents for a dollar you get if
you want trick-or-treat you make 40
bucks when I was a kid
there was only one catch when I was a
kid though
you had to be dressed up
you had to be dressed up because of my
neighborhood if you didn't get dressed
up the other kids would beat you up
that's how cold-blooded they were if
your parents didn't have money like the
clemensers and the old meals no was it
the O'Neills no the O'Neills were the
twins the Olsens
the ulcers were a family that were cool
as [__] I loved them to that but they
had like 22 [__] kids so they you
know it's a hard living and like a four
bedroom house and they live next to the
body shop on the Block and they always
smelt like paint it was
you know but those guys always like
didn't have enough costumes and [__] but
it's a different [__] world today
with kids man
I don't understand like the output can't
I don't think
one year they robbed my weed
remember in the in uh
before my daughter came and we were
already doing the podcast me I think
Felicia or Lee and I
I put candy out one night
and
buff we had to leave so before I left
there was no kids out so I went out to
the balcony to get high
and the next thing you [__] know
I was just a half a joint I put it under
the candy I put
I put the [__] I put the [__]
candy in a uh you know a pumpkin thing
like one of those containers you hold
with a [__] with a bucket
and
I put the bucket on top of the joint or
the joint behind the bucket I don't
[__] know I didn't want nobody to
find a joint I didn't have nobody would
have put the joint the door was already
locked
and next thing you know I [__] put
the joint under the thing when I went
out when I got back that night I went
out to smoke The Joint the candy was
still there but somebody had moved the
[__] thing one of the kids that's
taken my joints so they were on a
[__] triple themselves my friend
what's happening you bad [__]
this podcast is sponsored by better help
sometimes you can fix it in a problem
for so long that you don't take the time
to find the solution but when you learn
how to find your own Solutions there's
no better feeling a therapist can help
you accomplish
become a better Problem Solver make it
easier to accomplish your goals listen I
was with better help for a year and a
half Dana gave me exercises to control
my therapy to uh to therapy my anxiety
to slow it down
and for you guys that don't know better
help is an online therapy that offers
video phone and chat therapy sessions
you can choose not to see anyone on
camera if you like it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy when
you want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can help you get there visit
betterhelp.com
slash Diaz again that's betterhelp.com
Diaz I'm Gonna Get You ten percent off
your first month that's betterhelp.com
Diaz and now back to the podcast great
week though I finally I was telling Mike
that we had to go to a table read kind
of table read uh
we had to sing a song on this movie so
we had to sing a song as a cast
and it's off camera it's just
microphones
and then uh I've never done this before
guys either okay so this is all [__]
new to me
and uh it was very interesting guys I
got really uh
not motivated inspired man is that the
word we were talking about inspired by
Christopher Walken
it was funny because uh
I had to meet in Montclair
there's a recording studio there
pretty nice area I've never I'm in the
Montclair since 1980 [__] two or
something like that but I get up there I
get up there a little [__] early you
know Uncle Joey
I am sorry about my [__] hat this is
the new hairdo for the movie I'm sorry I
know a lot of these got to turn the
lights off in there they dyed my head of
[__] pieces uh I think it's too alive
but what are you gonna [__] do I
don't I only have to shoot one day this
week and then I go full time on the uh
seventh or whatever that [__]
yeah I think whatever next Monday is the
sixth the seventh
so I went up to Montclair [__] cool
[__] I went up there
I got there a little early I went for a
walk into town nobody I didn't see
anybody I saw some cops I saw some
people cute and then I walked back to
the recording studio and they said come
back about 2 30.
I got there about 2 30 I went upstairs
and uh
I go I'm here to feel it like that like
who are you and Joey I'm here to record
the [__] thing and they're like are
you part of the movie I go yeah
so I go back to the check-in they're
like no no no go in the other room there
it was like a studio
was telling Mike and I [__] go in
there and it's Christopher Walken and
Katherine Heigl guys and some of the
other actors like they'd be Sweeney I
didn't really know them I knew some
other guys from different things but I
didn't know what they were doing I shook
everybody's hand I shook Catherine
saying I should Christopher walk and say
I never met these guys before I never
met Chris walking before
so I [__] sit in my chair away from
them you know they were on the other
side of the room Christopher Walken was
talking to Catherine Heigl and I'm just
watching I don't know what they were
talking about
but I'm watching this [__] right
and director comes in and he starts
talking about uh you know what we're
gonna do today it's going to be a light
day
we're just going to sing this song and
then uh break us up into different
groups so everybody sings and it doesn't
have to be perfect this uh I'm not Elton
John you know what I'm saying this
doesn't have to be perfect we could just
[__] sing and I was okay with that
so we break up into the group so we
start singing That's Amore right you
know when uh pizza pie whatever That's
Amore right they give us the lyrics and
we got you know and I'm out there that's
I'm all day I'm trying it for more
different [__] I'm trying to sing
like Dom DeLuise I'm trying to edit for
more I'm trying to be a bass a stiletto
the whole [__] deal so soprano
stiletto
so now
I'm uh yeah I who the [__] knows I was
singing we're singing with singing bam
jontra Walter shows up he was stuck in
traffic
Travolta comes in hello we all say our
hellos you know
and all of a sudden we're uh again they
break us up into groups so it's like
Christopher Andrew Walton two other guys
me and four other guys the meech of
Walter and Christopher Walken to me uh
the only people I didn't sing were were
the women I always got mixed up with
different guys the women stayed on that
side of the room
so now uh we're there for a while but
you know Travolta's talking you know
he's talking uh whatever what he feels
now they're in conversations about
England we took breaks and everybody's
talking about England and this and that
yeah we're just talking about the World
Series Philadelphia Houston blah blah
blah
but the whole time everybody's talking
in this room there's got to be 20 people
Christopher Walken don't say dick
nothing but I keep going over and he's
one of those guys that just sits there
and watches you know like he's just
he's just watching you know with a nice
smile on his face he's not miserable
he got old
and uh
finally we all got to get up and sing
again and Travolta singing with
Catherine Heigl
and they really go into it they're
[__] looking at each other and going
away with the song and I'm looking at
Christopher Walken and he's not having
it you know what I'm saying he's like
what the [__] is this you know
so finally they they end and they go
you know Christopher you got to sing now
Chris whatever they call him Chris you
got to sing Mr walking he goes all right
you can tell he's old and [__] guys he
did not want to sing the last thing this
listen we're not saying is
this guy did not want to [__] sing
so
he finally gets up he's like I don't
know I'd feel more comfortable with
somebody else so yeah okay we put so a
guy goes up there with him but he's the
main guy he's an older and we want to
hear his voice you know and you could
tell he's a little embarrassed he you
know it's just you anybody could sing
with this 20 of us singing you know
Sweet Caroline
but you know you can't eat out bad
people sing but it's you by yourself
people could say that you [__] tone
deaf or whatever
he goes up there and I don't know what
the lyric was guys he blasted out he
goes yeah and we just busted out because
he was [__] hysterical I just [__]
died and you could see that
he looked at us and was like am I funny
it's okay for me to do that we're like
we didn't say yes or no he's [__]
Christopher walking and I'm saying
that's that's Christopher [__]
walking
but he looked at us
just to see like oh my God I did
something good as you can see he was
having a good time like an old dude you
know he's like okay let me do it again
and we're like all right go and he's
[__] singing the thing and he he
waves his arm now he's into it and just
by [__] I I told Mike just
he sat down and people were clapping and
we were having a [__] great time just
watching them do this I just got like
this tingle in my heart
like wow you know it doesn't [__]
matter how old you are that's still a
dangerous [__]
that's 40 Years of I'm looking at him
for a couple minutes and I'm like
what what movie haven't I seen with this
[__] guy
King of New York True Romance
Dear Hunter have you not seen deer
hunter lately has anybody not watched
Deer Hunter lately to see what the
strength of that movie is I would give
it out for the movie of the week but
it's like stealing
I can't believe you haven't seen [__]
deonta
I mean you know any movie this guy did
whether it's
the other one I like at close range that
that's one of his [__] best movies
this guy is his Saturday Night Live
appearances you guys know I can't stand
that live in any of that [__] but that
cowbell all that stuff with the [__]
with dog that dude can do com these are
old school people
you know what I'm sitting there watching
this guy going
God knows how many years he was down the
boat when Natalie Wood died right this
guy's seen some [__] this guy's seen
some [__] he ran with [__] when
people were real he knew De Niro and
[__] dinero was a kid
I mean you look at this guy and now he's
sitting there he's 78 years old whatever
the [__] he is
and he's still more dangerous than ever
it's just economical
like he's got to be economical with it
he doesn't have the energy to go [__]
12 hours of being the old Christopher
walking but
I was so guys and I would never say this
word but I was like inspired I'm like
this [__] I could do this to
Forever again I can't jump up and down
and do what he does he this guy's a
[__] genius
but it just lets you know that you're
gonna be [__] fine and also let me
know one thing
got nothing against nobody guys if
you're talented you're talented if
you're getting people to pay you money I
don't give a [__] if you put bottle
rockets up your ass and light them if I
meet you on the street I will shake your
hand and I'll shake the hand that you
stick the bottle rockets in your [__]
with that's the type of guy I am
but I also want you to understand one
thing
what's for today
and watch for 40 years from now
you know if you're a young guy right now
a 30 year old guy and you're figuring
out entertainment I want you to think
about your career path now because this
is important
but think away you're going to be in 30
years because I did as [__] junked up
as I was and drugged up and a [__]
criminal I always thought about this
time in my life
I didn't think about being 70 or 80. I
never even thought about being 60. but I
thought about my career later on down
the line and I've said this for years
guys
yeah listen you might come up with a
[__] Jazzy phrase
or video or something
to put you on the map right like that
that's all of us I I use the word
[__] you know I whatever we all
have something to put us on the map with
that's simple that's that's that's
Elementary [__]
you wanna
spread your word you know you want to do
comedy you want to do films you want to
be a musician you want to whatever you
want to be I want you to make yourself a
problem so you're going to be the best
[__] thing you could be
because you still want to do this
30 years later
and 30 years from now if you've been
doing it for six years that means you're
gonna have 36 years of this art under
your belt whether it's playing the bass
whether it's playing the guitar whether
it's singing acting comedy writing a
Blog podcasting all the above the skin
flute I don't give a [__] what you do I
mean seriously if you find a way to get
people to pay you God [__] bless you
God bless you but always think of the
long range always think of the talent
that's being developed when I look at
guys like
I watch all these old movies
because that's the era like that's the
guys that taught me to do what I'm doing
now when I see the job this week I
watched the [__] sting you know I
gave it out as a movie of the week so I
watch it I went on Prime video and I
watched it from the beginning I got I
ate some mushrooms the silly mushrooms I
smoked some pot [__] brilliant but
those guys Robert Redford like those
guys in that movie you don't see guys
like that no more you know you don't see
guys that were that committed that
probably went to Vaudeville that
probably worked in the circus when they
were kids Robert Redford was a [__]
soda jerk in Boulder at the [__] the
one coffee shop in Boulder I heard a
thousand stories he was just a kid that
worked I mean how does that what's that
got to do with him being an actor it
just lets you know that this kid was
doing something he was a young kid like
these guys put time into their craft
when I did the longest yard and I was
sitting there with Burt Reynolds in the
morning and he would tell stories about
him and his roommate at the time the guy
in the wheelchair in the movie about
bowling with the hook on his arm
I have a Big Lebowski The Big Lebowski
that was his room I forget what the
guy's name was how he [__] they were
in acting class and they had an audition
and a theater and the [__] guy
brought a gun to the audition he and he
threatened he liked Kazam at the
audition these guys were Savages
you know these guys were Savages yeah in
their lifestyle but they put that much
into their [__] craft
so nobody said they a Fly by Night
listen I'm a lot of [__] things but
I'm no [__] Fly by Night I put my
time into this [__] I studied stand up I
read the books and most importantly I
got on that stage all over this [__]
country on a Greyhound bus
because when I got to La I bombed one
night at The Improv like two years in
maybe 99 I took a bombing along with
getting my apartment towed along with
other [__] things that made me go you
know what man yeah la is great but I'm
not gonna get that good the good I'm
looking to get is not going to happen
going to The Comedy Store the Laugh
Factory or The Improv I'm telling you
right now I need real stage I need
[__] to be in holds every night watch
a hole a bar where and it's not a whole
like a bad place a hole is a bar where
people don't go there to laugh see when
people go to a comedy club the comedy
thing in their mind starts at two in the
afternoon what are you doing today
Mike's taking me to a comedy club we're
gonna do an animal we're gonna do a
mushroom it's gonna be so much fun you
see what I'm saying all these words
you're pre-programming yourself
we're gonna go see Tom Segura oh my God
you know you're pre-programming yourself
you know Mike and I always talk about
the open mic experience
I love the open mic experience because
it's where dreams go to die you know
it's like it's like that but it's like
that movie the accountant
when uh he's talking to the young girl
and he goes what college did you go to
and she's like Chicago University where
the party's going to die or something
some stupid joke you know you know I'm
talking about that movie where party's
going to die or whatever
the open mic is what Korea's dream is
going to die
you know dream is going to die if you're
a musician you see you know you you're
going out to do your thing and you're
putting on the black pants you listen to
Motley Crue Looks To Kill right she got
the Looks That Kill You you go down
there with your buddy who's got a nice
car right because he's got a better car
than you do she's like why don't you
give me a ride tonight she could pull up
with him and you go down there to
[__] do your thing and you're a
[__] bust out and on the better side
I've been there many nights when I've
been watching a young comedian special
with Rodney and Andrew going I'm going
to go down there and light those
[__] on fire with these new
jokes and I get down to this Cricket
night at the [__] LaRue Lounge so
always remember that going to a program
place a comedy club or meet buying
tickets two weeks before that's program
if I go to a hole which means Mike and I
are going for a drink
to talk about why Mike's girlfriend in
the fifth grade left them for the bully
you know what I'm saying you ever get
the you get those calls during the week
I had to talk to you need to have a
drink you know I just remembered in high
school you spit my eye whatever the [__]
it was
you know when you go down there and all
of a sudden you're like you'll walk into
a place like what the [__] is this
and there's a music some guy with an
acoustic guitar singing like something
that you've heard 10 million times or
you ever go into a place where there's
comedy
and you wanted to go talk or watch a
football game
and you watch the football game for a
while
but this kid keeps [__] talking and
then you hear the laughter and then
after a while you're intrigued you're
like well let me see what they're
laughing about and you look over and you
don't want to laugh
you don't want to laugh you want to
watch that football game
but he says something that makes you
laugh that guy is funnier than the guy
you went to see at the comedy club
Joey how do you justify I'm
that guy just made you laugh in a hole
it's a hole it's not a whole has a
shitty bar it's just a hole where people
do not go watch Comedy you went down to
do comedy when I started at the broker
it was a hole I was a host and it was a
great show and it was great two
comedians but it was a whole why because
I had to make people not laugh
I had to make people stop and watch me
while they ate that prime rib
that's completely [__] different
that's the bottom line with that [__] so
my point you're like Joey why are you
giving me a beating with the whole I'm
giving you an ear beat with the whole
because
anybody could succeed with something
like I I assume all right let's
I don't like videos okay in my journey
of being comic I got into videos and one
of the First videos I got success one
was like a third one I had done was Joey
karate
I thought I was big and bad I thought it
was the next Tarantino
you know you know how hard it is to take
two one million hit videos back to back
I tell you what you could do two out of
ten
and then you could do
three out of 25 or 3 out of 35.
that'll hit a million but the more
videos you shoot
the least hits you're gonna get the
least and the more the quicker you put
them out like if you put them on every
[__] day now you're just gonna burn
people out
so you have to learn away on how to put
them out without pissing people off with
them wanting you to see it is it the
third day is it the fourth day is it the
fifth day it doesn't really matter my
point is that
when I got into the video business
people wanted to see me for the Joey
karate videos and they wanted me to make
content for what was their videos
when I sat down and went and tried to
make that content for their videos I
didn't do too well yeah some of the
videos were great but I learned about
the video business quickly
that your level of video has to be up
you know my dear friend one of the great
video makers today
Vic
makes 50 potato makes 10 to 12 videos a
day you get to see one it's hard making
those videos and it's hard to keep doing
it but
what I'm trying to get at here
is that you learned another skill I
learned the video skill do I still shoot
videos ah once in a while not really
but all those skills led up to where I
am today
so when I was watching Christopher
Walken the other day
and he did that move first of all he
didn't say a [__] word he just sat
there and watched your Walter talk
Catherine Heigl talk the director talked
that guy that guy had the most talent in
that in that room by [__] a mile I
just broke down his credits to you all
those movies this guy did Vaudeville
this guy's the real deal so I might live
it takes a lot to have
all that in your [__] treasure chest
in your
in your arsenal of weapons
no it bro that dude's got an Arsenal
weapons but to see that guy get up at
whatever age he is let's clock him in
78.
and still have what it takes
lets you know that putting the work in
is always [__] great it's [__]
tremendous man
it is
it'll go with you forever
that's why I don't care that I don't
have a lot of the other accolades that
comedians have you know what I'm a great
[__] headliner
I'm a way better feature but I'm a
tremendous MC
tremendous
and you're like yeah but Joe you don't
make money as I'm saying that's fine I
didn't get into comedy and make money I
didn't get this emptying to make money I
could look in the face and tell you I'm
really good as a [__] MC way better
than the headline there's no money in
the MC but I did that because I didn't
want to cover all the bases
I wanted to cover all the bases I wanted
to make sure that when I got to this
level there was no misunderstandings
with [__] anybody or the biggest
misunderstanding would be with myself
you either gonna pay me now or you're
gonna [__] pay me later
that's an old Pennzoil commercial but I
have to repeat it to myself for years
over over because it was the biggest
fear that I ever had
okay when I went for that dinero movie
and I
listen with the pandemic and [__] and
I'm not whining we got out of practice
I got out of practice
you know number one I'm not an actor to
begin with so I got out of practice
so when I started popping these
auditions
they all started you know when you have
one audition every three months you're
not gonna get the Rhythm back
you're never going to get the Rhythm
back that you had when you audition
every day it's like I tell you guys
about stand up if I'm doing stand up
every night like I used to 20 years ago
every night and not just for one week
for five years in a row when you do
stand up every night
that's who your mind is you're
constantly a [__] machine gun over
and over again
I don't uh
I don't [__] I never wanted to sweat
that guys I never want to be in a forum
where I wasn't prepared and I see a lot
of people now
that aren't prepared for the next level
after the pandemic I saw 20 Comics pop
up out of nowhere good for them you just
heard me say I love when somebody
[__]
bust a [__] hump but I love when
people get somebody to pay them I really
[__] do I don't give a [__] however
they do it they made you go in your
wallet to pay them but all these Comics
picked up
I see a lot of new faces and I know a
lot of them should I don't care how many
[__] sets you did during the pandemic
because for six months half of us were
doing sets at the [__] house in front
of a zoo but I guarantee guys even the
guys that did sets like I didn't do no
Zoom sets but I know people who must
have done 100 Zoom sets and I guarantee
that comedy went a different direction
also it built a different muscle
it built up it built a different muscle
that they didn't even know they had I
don't even know what that muscle is but
I Knew by doing anything you're just
building up to the final result and
that's what I got the other day from
watching Christopher walking in a
[__] shitty rehearsal that nobody
else is looking at or paying attention
at me being the geek that I am I pay
attention to that [__] so always
remember whatever you pick up and on my
patreon I have a lot of young Comics
that ask for advice and I love that they
do but I instill that into all of them
listen
don't rush the process
take that process and take it in how old
are you well I'm 38 uh
bro I didn't even see daylight till I
was 50. but every year I got stronger at
my craft and I got stronger what I did I
told you [__] when I did Marin
the first time I did married
I couldn't believe I was that good and
you know guys I don't I'm not an ego
type of guy but I couldn't and not only
good is like acting wise but how I knew
my way around everything I knew where to
stand I knew where to go I I just knew
you're just familiar that even I shocked
myself the way Christopher Walken
shocked himself when we were laughing at
him the other day it's [__] just
great guys my whole point on a Monday
morning
is if you're gonna do something [__]
do it go for it learn it inside and
[__] out you you got nothing but time
I'd rather you do it now than I have to
come back and do it later and somebody
says to you all you your [__] writing
isn't good listen I know my strengths
and I know my weaknesses but my
strengths are so [__] strong that
they hide the weaknesses
you know energy for me on stage I would
always beat the other guy by energy
because if you go meow and I go meow and
I you follow me energy is a complete
different it's a [__] artist
that's what I would do when I would go
on stage like I said you got to figure
out I don't give a [__] how you get for
them to give you money
but you have to figure it out and that's
what I figured out that when I used
energy I became 50 funnier just by
getting mad
just by getting mad and just wrangling
off the top of my [__] head people go
holy [__] you need to rant more I never
even knew that was a [__] rant my
point is guys if you're gonna [__]
walk on Ice you might as well dance if
you're gonna take on an art take on an
occupation go for it 150 [__] learn
everything you can about it some kid hit
me up two months ago and Joey I disagree
with you when you talked about you watch
singers to help you with your comedies
that's right you don't have to agree
with me
but where the [__] are you standing and
where the [__] am I standing do you find
what I'm saying to you we all have
different ways that we learn from people
I learned about comedy when I go to jiu
jitsu
I learned about comedy sometimes when I
watch music when I see a guitarist
and I also learned about comedy when I
watch [__] comedy so
however works for you [__] it's
Monday October the 31st it's [__]
Halloween I'm fired up I'm gonna go to a
[__] I'm gonna go trick-or-treating
with my daughter and her little Goombas
and then I'm going to a [__]
Halloween party at my friends I'm gonna
eat some [__] Edibles I'm gonna eat
some [__] mushrooms and then I'm
getting ready for Wednesday night at the
[__] Sony theater it's uh what
is it off All Souls day is Tuesday
tomorrow
and All Saints Day it's Tuesday it's
Tuesday Wednesday so I'll see you
[__] Wednesday Tip Top Magoo
ready to go Leo be here we're gonna
[__] burn that [__] thing down
George Perez will be here Felicia
Michaels will be here Wednesday night
and that's all you [__] need to
know I love you stay black
and I'll see you [__] Wednesday
and hear a word for my [__]
sponsors Jack all right you filthy
animals I want to thank you on a Monday
morning for listening it's the Uncle
Joey short Monday Morning podcast we got
[__] to do on people to see the joint is
brought to you by Better Health listen I
love better help why because sometimes
we fix that on problems for so long that
we don't find time to help the solution
better help
wolf help you find your solution and I
tell you to do when you do there's no
better feeling a therapist can help you
accomplish to become a better Problem
Solver for yourself making it easier to
accomplish your goals and what you want
to do and what makes you happy in life
better help is online therapy that
offers your video phone and chat therapy
sessions you can choose not to see
anyone on camera or you could see 10
people on camera whatever you want it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and I'll get you a therapist
between 48 Hours try looking for a
therapist today with all the problems in
the world good luck but here at better
help we got you so do me a favor become
a better Problem Solver visit
betterhelp.com
Diaz again that's betterhelp.com Diaz
and if you go today I'm going to get you
10 off your first month that's better
hope.com slash Diaz the joint is also
brought to you by one of my favorites
liquid IV that's the first thing I do in
the morning I get a cold bottle of water
16 ounce I put a package of liquid IV in
there and I'm ready to rock Jack one
stick of liquid IV will get you hydrated
faster two times faster than water alone
listen the concord grape the lemon lime
the tropical punch the Cherry I love
them all the acai berry
what makes liquid IV so effective is the
cellular transport technology designed
to enhance absorption of water into your
bloodstream look at liquid IV is non-GMO
it contains five essential vitamins
b356 B12 and vitamin C and three times
the electrolytes guys three times
of traditional Sports trains so do me a
favor grab your liquid IV and bulk
nationwide at Costco if you got the time
but I'm Gonna Save You 15 off when you
go to liquid ib.com slash Joey again
liquid iv.com Joey that's 15 off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration at liquid iv.com Joey I want
to thank better hope I want to thank
liquid IV but I want to thank you guys
for always having my back stay black
have a happy Halloween with your kids
and don't eat no fentanyl [__] suckers
I'll see you guys on Wednesday
[Music]
foreign